15-inch MacBook Air or 14 inch MacBook
Pro well it is a hard Choice especially
if you upgrade your SSD and RAM on the
MacBook but in this video we are going
to compare everything from the design
the displays the speakers the webcam and
of course the performance and battery
life to help you make a great choice
both of these machines have 16 gigs of
RAM and 512 gigabytes of SSD and what
makes this a tougher choice is that
right now on Amazon you can get the 14
inch pro for 17.50 only 50 bucks more
than the MacBook Air so should you get
it well let's start out with the
external differences as you guys could
see the display difference is quite
shocking I thought they'd be a lot more
similar but the 15 inch has a noticeably
larger screen and with that as far as
the dimensions you guys could see the 15
inch is obviously larger let me stack
this up it is quite quite noticeable the
footprint of the 15 inch is longer it is
taller but of course with that this 15
inch is really really thin the full air
is literally the same thickness as just
the main body of the 14 inch and if you
open them side by side it literally
lines up with the ports so the thinness
of the 15 inch is incredible and it's
not only for the wow factor of it being
thin if you are typing on the keyboards
which feel identical on both on the 15
inch it's so thin that your wrists are
above this edge here compared to the 14
inch where you definitely feel them if
you're typing for a while that can dig
in after a little bit the track pad on
the 15 inch is also larger than on the
14 inch but in reality I don't think
that really makes a big difference now
as far as the weight the specs make them
seem very similar we have 3.3 pounds
compared to 3.5 but in the hand the 14
inch feels a lot heavier because it is
smaller thicker and heavier of course in
your laptop bag you will not notice a
difference but just holding them the 15
inch air just feels impossibly thin and
light and you do get that enjoyment
factor and another cool Factor
difference is that the ear is available
in four colors you have your space gray
and silver just like the 14 inch pro but
you also have Starlight and this
midnight blue color which is gorgeous
but it is a crazy fingerprint magnet now
as far as ports both of these have fast
charging magsafe ports both have two
Thunderbolt ports on the left side and
the pro has the headphone jack but the
differences come in on the opposite side
the pro gives us an additional
Thunderbolt Port we have an HDMI 2.1
port and we have a fast SD card reader
which is definitely nice if you are a
creative or if you want to hook up to
additional displays and speaking of
displays the 14 inch can actually hook
up to three displays externally compared
to just one for the MacBook Air so that
is a big limitation and if you care
about that that could be a deal breaker
before we move on I want to share our
sponsor's really useful app clean my Mac
X to clean protect and optimize your Mac
now many of your favorite YouTubers love
it and I've used it for over three years
because it is simple powerful and fast
clean my Mac X can delete files quickly
and automatically including hidden
leftover junk files and the lens tool
helped me find and delete a forgotten 55
gigabyte backup that was wasting space
it could also auto update apps scan and
delete malware cleanup cache monitor
health and much more if you're unsure
what to run the assistive
recommendations will let you know and if
your Mac is running slow their menu
provides a ton of useful info along with
the free up memory button that takes
just one click to run it's been on the
market for 14 years and it's on the App
Store so it is safe use the link in the
description to try all the features with
a 7 day free trial or buy it with our 20
off discount Link in the description for
the next two weeks now as far as the
speakers this is where it's going to get
interesting we take apart the 15-inch
MacBook Air and shows you guys those
speaker modules and they are way bigger
than the 13 inch Apple put in a six
speaker system just like in the 14 inch
if you guys want to see the full tear
down you guys can see it so we'll link
it below but let's see if the new 15
inch can compete
[Music]
as you guys heard the 14 inch does still
sound better yes it's smaller but it's
quite a bit thicker so the speaker
modules have more room in there with
that said the 15 inch is not far behind
and is way better than the previous
MacBook airs so personally I wouldn't
make this Choice based off speakers
because the 15 inch still sounds
fantastic now both these MacBooks have
1080p webcams this one right here is the
14 inch MacBook Pro which has studio
quality microphones and this is the
15-inch MacBook Air now you guys let me
know which one looks better and which
microphones sound better to you down in
the comments and to me I do notice that
because the 50 teenage a little bit
taller the angle is actually a little
bit better but the quality might be
slightly worse so let me know and now
let's get into displays because we have
a lot of differences first off you guys
saw the size difference and when I got
used to using the 15 inch since we got
it go into the 14 inch it makes it seem
small so if you want more real estate
you want things to be larger on the
screen the 15 inch is better but with
that said it actually has less pixels we
have 5.3 million compared to 5.9 total
so this thing has a higher pixel density
it's sharper but realistically looking
at text right now it's hard to tell a
difference now what's more noticeable is
the difference in refresh rate the 15
inch has a 60 hertz panel compared to
Pro motion up to 120 hertz so in the
slow motion footage you guys could see
the difference now looking at this right
now I do see that the 14 inch is
smoother but it's not by as big of a
difference as you get on an iPhone with
the pro model or maybe an iPad that's a
lot more jarring on the 60hz so I don't
know what else could be different but if
you're going to be gaming or you want
just extra smoothness the 14 inch is
definitely better and the even bigger
difference is the fact that the MacBook
gear has a LCD display compared to mini
LED on the 14 inch so this thing can
actually go up to 1600 nits of
brightness in HDR content now regular
viewing right now I have both displays
maxed out in brightness so you guys see
they're very similar because they both
run at 500 nits now in the past the
MacBook Air had a lower brightness
screen a lower color accuracy right now
that actually matches up in standard
content but if you're looking at HDR
content that is where the 14 inches
display really shines where you have
really really bright highlights it looks
amazing compared to standard kind of
look on the 15 inch air and with that
the contrast that you get in the 14 inch
especially in Darker environments really
stands out it's pure dark compared to a
grayish screen on the Macbook so for
movies the 14 inch screen definitely
looks better now you can get some
blooming on the 14 inch especially if
you have pure black with pure white
content or if you're looking off angle
and that can be distracting sometimes
but it is better than having the whole
screen be great and of course if you
want to do HDR editing then you need a
14 inches display but for a lot of
people using it regularly in normal
rooms they will still be happy with the
15 inch and now it is time to compare
the performance because that's what
makes a lot of people want to get the 14
inch of course it has the M2 Pro
processor and inside it has a couple
fans to keep that cool whereas the 15
inch MacBook gear is completely fanless
and a tiny motherboard and the cooler on
there well it's almost non-existent so
yes it has less cores and it could also
Throttle Down but let's see how much of
a difference that makes in the real
world now starting out I want to run an
SSD test because both of these have 512
gigs of SSD and as you guys can see the
results are practically identical uh we
have the Reed that is just slightly off
but it can vary and that's because the
ssds are identical in both of these now
of course if you get the 256 gig base
SSD and the 15 inch air well that is
half the speed or maybe even a little
bit slower which can affect performance
especially if you're multitasking so the
512 is worth it and now comparing the
CPU performance we have the M2 versus
the bend M2 Pro so we have a course
compared to 10 and let's see how the CPU
performance Compares and here we go in
terms of single course score the results
are practical within margin of error the
clock speeds are the same their
performance cores are the same but
multi-core score we have 9900 compared
to 12 300. so that is the difference of
just over 24
which makes kind of sense because well
we have more performance cores six
instead of four so we'll see how that
relates to real world use and now I have
figma a web-based design app opened up
right here and this project is brought
To Us by 500 designs in Design Studio in
La they are one of the best and zooming
in and out here on various points in the
project everything is insanely smooth
with these high resolution graphics
you guys saw I just took a second to
load that there let's go ahead and test
out the 14 inch M2 Pro
performance is basically the same and
that's what I found even with a fanless
machine for stuff like this it does not
matter and I've selected 12 high
resolution layers and we are going to
export these and we're going to see how
long they take and this is using both
the CPU and the graphics to do that and
Bam alright so that took a minute 48
seconds on the 15 inch air and a minute
and 38 seconds on the M2 Pro so for
tougher web-based apps that is a little
bit faster but not by much and for those
of you guys to do more simple web-based
tabs speedometer 2.0 shows us that the
performance is basically the same so
keep that in mind now what about if you
really push the machines well I've seen
a bench opened up right here it's going
to max out the CPUs the first test I'm
going to do is just a single run this is
going to give us our Baseline and look
at this after just about 30 seconds
we're hitting 108 degrees Celsius on
this Mac 85 on this and you might say
yeah well it has two fans if you guys
look closer the fans are still off that
is because you have heatsinks and heat
pipes that are absorbing some of the
heat we're here with the 15 inch air
just goes into the chassis and even
after just a minute you see the 15 inch
air does start to throttle where this
one the performance is the same and we
have our scores here we have
7893 for the 15-inch air and 11 040 for
the 14 inch pro that is a difference of
40 percent higher than what we would
expect with that core clock difference
and the core count of course we have a
little bit of throttling here and that's
in just a test it takes about a minute
and a half and now I'm gonna go ahead
and switch to the 10 minute throttling
test and let's see what happens with a
longer workload right out of the gate
the M2 Pro is pulling 25 watts compared
to about 19.6 so we have more power draw
which means more heat more battery usage
which we'll talk about in just a bit and
it looks like the 15 inch is already
slowing down its clock speeds and it is
quite hot while the 14 inch is staying
steady and if you thought that the 14
inch is going to run much cooler look at
this we're hitting 103 degrees Celsius
on multiple cores here because apple is
prioritizing having the fans turned down
low just to keep it completely
at least they're okay with having those
higher temps so if you're thinking about
getting an air because it's silent well
the 14 inch pro pretty much is silent
all the time but the beauty of it is
that you can get TG fan Pro and you can
make your own fan curve to run a little
faster to keep it cooler I'll go ahead
and Link that down in the description as
you guys see the pro has completely
consistent in terms of performance
whereas our air throttle down to about
2.9 gigahertz 15 watts and it seems to
be staying there and we're getting close
to the 10 minute Mark so I want to do a
temp test we're at 46 degrees at the
hottest on the air
and on the 14 it's just screen's
actually hotter let's look down here 45
so same temperature at the little Center
but if you guys look the heat actually
spreads out more so on the 15 inch
because on the 14 inch we have the fan
that's pushing the exhaust towards that
screen we have a result and wow okay so
our 15 inch air got
7485 compared to
11054. I am shocked by how little
performance the 15 inch air lost when it
was throttling quite a bit it was using
a lot less power the clock speeds were
lower compared to this one fully
consistent that's a difference of 47
which is a lot but at the same time when
they just did a quick run it was 40 so
even in this throttles it runs more
efficiently but the performance doesn't
go down by that much now what about
graphics performance I'm going to run
the new geekbench 6 which takes a lot
longer here and we have a 10 core GPU
compared to a 16 core that's a big
difference and it looks like we have a
difference of 60 sent 45 500 compared to
seventy three thousand three hundred
which is the exact difference in terms
of GPU cores so that makes sense but it
is a big difference now what does that
mean in terms of gaming performance well
I have 3D Marks Wildlife extreme open
here I'm going to run the unlimited mode
which is going to make it fair because
we do have different screen resolutions
and here we see a slightly higher
difference we have 41.2 FPS compared to
67.1 that's a difference of 63 percent
in this quick run but that's not all how
much will the 15 inch throttle if you
have a longer gaming session I'm going
to do the stress test here which is 20
minutes long and dang look at that
difference guys first off here our
stability is 99.6 meaning even after 20
minutes of gaming the difference is
pretty much non-existent you guys see
that score is flat whereas on the 15
inch air it started out 6812 but then it
was just drop dropped other than this
blip it went down to 5505 with a
stability score of 80 percent so 20 of
the performance for FPS is lost and if
we do the math this difference here is
double so yeah for gaming you literally
get double the performance with the M2
Pro 14 inch if you're playing say for
more than about 10 minutes or so and
that is massive now what about for
everybody out there that is running
xcode can you get away with a 15 inch
ear that is thin and light I'm going to
run our xcode Benchmark here using the
terminal commands to keep it fair and
we'll see how long it takes and here you
go guys we have
122.5 seconds compared to 98.2 that's a
difference of about 25 so yes even in
xcode that difference is definitely
noticeable now as far as photo editing I
have Lightroom classic opened up right
here and the first thing I notice is the
difference in display size sure you can
edit off of the 14 inch you still see
everything but you definitely get a
larger image on the 15 inch but what
about the performance well of course if
you're just going to be switching
through images you're not going to see a
difference even if these really high
resolution edited images have to reload
everything each time I click now
Lightroom has this new Ai denoise and
enhanced function and I'm gonna go ahead
and run this the 14 inch is definitely
ahead here as you guys can see the
graphics are maxed out and we are using
some CPU we have to use more on the 15
inch because it has less performance and
that took a minute and 17 seconds for
the air compared to 51 seconds for the
pro that's for a 42 megapixel single
image that's a difference of 50 percent
and of course if you're going to be
doing that to a ton of images at once
that difference will add up and now I'm
going to run the export test with 500
images now in the past we just did 50
but these machines are getting so fast
now and we know the 15 inch can throttle
so we wanted to up it just like we did
with higher end Max and right away you
guys could see that we are getting hot
on the air we're using a lot of CPU and
Graphics the 14-inch Pro actually needs
less CPU power because it's not limited
by that and it's interesting how much
more power the 14 inch is sucking at
times uh double the power for the CPU
and Graphics combined oh geez
dang okay now look at this guys the
frequency dropped like crazy here just
because when we have both the CPU and
GPU going so high you get more
throttling so this is the really the
toughest test and we'll see the
difference in time the 14 inch is almost
done and I think this might have been a
bad idea because the air isn't maybe
half done here now here's one thing that
most reviewers will not tell you I've
been waiting for a while here and now
our CPU temperature is down to 74
degrees Celsius super cool and why is
that well it's because
after such a long time the whole system
throttles itself down even if it's not
that hot to keep the base of the case
cool you guys could see we're running
the performance cores at about a
gigahertz that is crazy from running at
3.2 so it makes it drag on okay guys
finally that's a Forever on the air
oh the 14 inch took 11 minutes and 9
seconds compared to 25 minutes and 35
seconds on the air that's more than
double the time so when you look at
regular just simple benchmarks you can't
just look at that because if you're
doing long intensive workloads that is
where the air falls apart now you guys
let me know if you want me to do the
thermal mod video that I've done on
previous models and talk about battery
degradation and those kind of
misconceptions comment down below but
here you guys see that's a crazy crazy
difference so if you're doing quick
photo editing exporting a few files it's
fine but with long stuff like this man
now but what about video editing I have
Final Cut opened up right here with a
five minute 4K standard project that is
color graded with some Luts and film
grain and as far as playing this back
these both have media engines they're
playing back perfectly the only
difference we see is that the 15 inches
using about 70 75 percent of the
graphics compared to about 47 to 50
percent uh just because it needs to use
less of its performance to handle this
so you get a little bit more overhead
for more effects on the 14 inch and now
I'm gonna go ahead and Export this five
minute graded project and we'll see how
long it takes and they are moving at
basically the same time showing that the
hebc encoders are identical here and
because we're not limited by CPU
Graphics we're not pushing the systems
too hard you're not going to get
throttling issues with this kind of
standard projects and that took two
minutes and 21 seconds compared to 2
minutes and 22 for the 14 inch basically
the same time which is great if you're a
regular video editor now both of these
have prores decoders and encoders which
is very very awesome even in a cheaper
system and here I have a graded 4K press
raw project both are playing it back
perfectly I'm going to export these to
prores 422 and here the 14 inch is
speeding ahead and we will see a
difference long term because the
graphics are maxed out on both and that
took a minute and 41 seconds on the air
and a minute and three seconds on the
pro so that's roughly 50 or a bit higher
than that difference which makes sense
because of the graphics and then with
that this was a longer 20 minute project
we would be getting some more throttling
on the 15 inch so as you guys could see
for simple stuff the air still does
great even with different effects
stacked but when you start getting into
prores and if you do even tougher raw
footage that doesn't use proraz well
that's where you definitely want the 14
inch and now what about the battery life
difference senses well our 14 inch does
have a larger battery and has a smaller
display but with that has the M2 Pro
that has more cores and it runs more
power to the display for HDR viewing now
Apple rates the air for 18 hours of
battery life but that's for video
playback and that's the same as the 13
inch and the 14 inch but if we look at
web browsing all of a sudden we get a
three hour difference in battery life
now in real world mixed use the battery
life is lower but you'll still will see
a two to three hour better battery life
on the air now with that said we've been
running a ton of tests we've been
recording for hours and our 14 inches
now at 25 battery life and let's see
what our 15-inch gets
we are at 32 now keep in mind that for
some of these tests the 14-inch got them
done way faster so it actually saved
battery because it was able to just sit
there while for some the 15 inch
throttled and used a lot less power for
the M2 Chip which saved battery but
overall if you care about the best
battery life the 15 inch will give you a
few extra hours now with that we have
another difference and that is Wi-Fi
speed now I did a video comparing Wi-Fi
6 to 6E on the new M2 Pro laptops there
I upgraded my router tested a bunch of
different locations but the weird thing
that I found is that even if you don't
have a 6E router just regular Wi-Fi six
five gigahertz I got way faster speeds
with the new M2 Pro with the Wi-Fi 6E
chip and I also got better range in
tough spots so even if you don't have
fast internet you'll get better
reception and better speed where you
didn't before and it is weird that for
the 15 inch air Apple did not give us
Wi-Fi 6E even though the M2 Mac Mini did
get it so if you care about Wi-Fi speeds
and getting the best range and reception
the 14 inch is definitely better in that
regard as well so to answer the original
question which one of these should you
buy well I think that after all these
tests it is very obvious that the 14
inch is a much better laptop especially
if you care about performance if you
want to watch HDR movies or videos the
screen is better you have more ports the
speakers sound better as well it is a
better laptop overall and especially if
you get it for 17.50 on Amazon using the
link below that's a screaming deal now
you can actually get the MacBook 15 inch
ears discounted on Amazon as well so
link that below but if you're upgrading
your RAM and your SSD and you're getting
close to the 14 inch it makes it a much
worse deal but with that said you guys
saw some of those tests for yourself and
some of them there was very little
difference you also get a much thinner
and lighter laptop as well you get a
larger screen which I enjoy so I think
it really comes down to the Pro versus
not pro naming for once that actually
means something so if you're doing
professional tasks you're really pushing
your machine you need those ports you
get the pro if you don't you do simple
tasks web-based things or quick video
edits that aren't too tough and quick
photo edits the air is super thin and
light has a beautiful large display not
as good but it still is great and you
enjoy that thinness and lightness so
hopefully that helps you guys out to see
real world tests with your particular
use case if you guys enjoy detailed
videos like these please hit that
subscribe button go ahead and check out
one of those great videos over there we
have a lot more coming with info for you
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]